[Musique]
oh
si vous êtes yvelinois ouverte à y est
vous avez peut-être reconnu ce lieu je
me trouve au potager du roi en compagnie
de stéphanie tesson bonjour bonjour vous
avez mise en scène les verts paradis ans
et ça ce spectacle déambulatoire qui
aura lieu ce samedi 11 juin et dimanche
12 juin alors est-ce que vous pouvez
peut-être me présenter ce spectacle avec
plaisir vert paradis s'est tue un
spectacle promenade qui se déploie en
une dizaine de tableaux les tableaux
sont mis en vie plutôt qu'en 5 kg a pas
de scène ici ni envers diome ans filles
ont mis dans ce superbe endroit qu'est
le potager du roi et c'est une sorte
d'anthologie de la vivante de la nature
c'est comme ça qu'on la présente c'est
cette dizaine de tableaux puise dans le
répertoire littéraire poétique musical
théâtral de la littérature française on
a aussi un garcia lorca est aussi on a
hildegarde de bingen une grande
prêtresse allemande du 12e siècle qui
nous a fait l'honneur de nous rejoindre
et on est allé chercher leurs textes
parce que ce sont tous des amoureux de
la nature d'abord qui savent en parle et
qui savent la célébrer qui savent
l'honorer avec leurs mots leur esprit
leur âme et qui rencontrent chez tous
les artistes qui réunit ma compagnie
phénomène les compagnies des échos
incarnez que nous offrons aux
spectateurs de ce week end et justement
c'est dans le cadre donc du mois molière
donc cet événement tout le mois de juin
donc à versailles pour donc célébré
molière donc ici qu'est ce que vous
allez qu'est ce que vous allez vous
faire découvrir aux spectateurs
alors ce mois molière en effet si
françois de mazières le maire de
versailles qu'il offre aux habitants de
la ville et aux artistes qui l'invité
qui fidélise autour de lui depuis une
vingtaine d'années qu'il existe 26 ans
exactement et on propose dans des lieux
légendaires historique de la ville des
spectacles à foison souvent en libre
accès souvent enfin qui sont très très
abordable à toutes les bourses et nous
nous proposons cette promenade dans le
merveilleux potager du roi qui a été
créée par la quintinie pour servir de
garde manger à louis xiv
au xviie siècle et nous nous la bi ton
d'une manière un peu particulière avec
ma troupe d'artistes
c'est à dire ça fait 20 ans que nous
habitons donc on a pris à racines lui en
proposant aux spectateurs de tous âges à
partir de 8 ans de rentrer comme dans un
livre ouvert dans ses tableaux un peu
féerique grâce à des comédiens qui
jouent qui interprète soit un coq soit
un poète soit eu un cafard ici ou là qui
se travestissent qui incarne ses
multiples aspects de la nature pour en
sortir le sucre poétique et d'offrir aux
familles qui viennent nous voir alors
comment vous avez conçu ce spectacle à
bonne question en me baladant moi-même
en voyageant dans la littérature
autour du thème de la nature qui est
depuis les origines de de l'inspiration
de l'homme de la poésie depuis la genèse
où depuis le premier livre de la
création qui est une source
d'inspiration sans fin
la nature dans tous ses états comme
toujours bienfaitrice de l'homme comme
maire de lomme et c'est très étonnant de
voir que dans la littérature en général
la nature est toujours associé aux biens
c'était chez les grecs il y avait même
une déesse de la nature mais c'est la
mère porteuse c'est la mer matrix et
l'homme n'a eu de cesse de la la chanter
en fait et c'est ce champ simplement
dénué de toute intention politique
ce chant d'amour que nous voulons lui
rendre avec ce spectacle est alors à qui
est destiné finalement ce spectacle et
que c'est exclusivement aux amoureux de
la nature mais c'est à tous les gens qui
ont envie d'entrer au paradis
il s'appelle vert paradis c'est à tous
ceux qui qui aime
se perdre dans un rêve le temps de d'une
promenade dans un rêve d'enfance
d'innocence de beauté d'amour de gaieté
de de jeu
à travers ces cette espèce de d'étranges
rêves vivant que nous pouvons continuer
à tisser ici avec avec phénomène et
compagnie ma trousse madama troupes
depuis 20 ans que les jardiniers du
potager met à disposition ce lieu c'est
simplement permettre aux spectateurs de
respirer l'odeur de la vie et du théâtre
vivant au milieu des herbes mais c'est
merveilleux de parler d'un papillon et
de le voir devant vous autrement qu'en
plastique ou en images de synthèse voyez
c'est comme ça qu'on conçoit ce
spectacle on est dans le vrai dans la
vie dans la nature et on en parle en
même temps et on espère faire du bien à
tous ceux qui viennent nous a très bien
on leur donne les dates samedi 11 et
dimanche 12 juin c'est à quelle heure à
partir de 17 heures toutes les 30
minutes il ya un départ de promenades il
ya deux promenades le jardin des
mystères le jardin des poètes et on peut
faire les deux elle dure une heure
chacune si on arrive à peu près à ces
taux entre 17h et 19h il ya cinq ou six
départs comme ça toutes les demi heures
et on peut alternativement je voulais de
promenade très bien elle va le rendez
vous est pris merci beaucoup stéphane et
et merci à vous
[Musique]